SPEAKER: At just about
every organization,
it's someone's job to prepare
slide decks that contain lots
of informative data points.
Now this process often involves
writing queries and then
manually adding the
results into each slide.
But who wants to spend all
that time copying and pasting?
Well, we're about to make
your life a whole lot easier.
In this video, we'll
walk through how
you can use Google Apps
Scripts to automate
data driven slide development.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's imagine you're a data
analyst on the e-commerce team
for a huge retailer.
Each week, you're tasked
with preparing Google Slides
for the director to present
to the broader team.
The problem, this is a
super time consuming task.
You're going to need to query
the e-commerce data to come up
with the total sales, new
customers, number of orders,
and repeat purchase rate.
But wait.
That's not it.
There are more than 20
different departments,
and each one needs
their own slide.
My thumb and index
fingers are hurting just
thinking about all those
Control-C and Control-Vs.
Lucky for you, your
company already
has their e-commerce data
living inside of BigQuery.
And one of the many great
things about BigQuery
is the flexibility
it offers in terms
of interacting with your data.
BigQuery has a variety of
APIs, client libraries, and out
of the box integrations with
different Google services,
all of which make it easy
to access your data where
and when you need it.
In this tutorial, we'll
be using BigQuery's API
as a service that's natively
available in Google Apps
Script.
All right.
Ready?
Let's jump in.
So the first step in automating
the development of these slides
is to define our
metrics using SQL.
Let's say it will calculate
total sales for each slide
by filtering our orders to a
specific department on a given
week, then summing up the total
sales of all the items ordered.
Now, to ensure
we're consistently
calculating our
metrics, we can go ahead
and create a user-defined
function inside of BigQuery.
With our function defined,
we can run it any time
we need to calculate
total sales simply
by feeding in a department
name and week timestamp.
But what about actually
pushing the results
of this function into a slide?
One option for programmatically
developing slides
is to create a template slide
that we'll use for formatting.
Here, I've created a
pretty simple template
where variables that will
be programmatically pushed
into our slide are surrounded
by distinguishable characters,
like these double
curly brackets.
In my template, I can control
things like where on the slide
these variables
should be printed
and the color of the text.
Great.
So we have our template
all ready to go.
Now to actually run
the calculations
and populate this
template, we'll
turn to Google Apps Script.
Google Apps Script is
a scripting environment
for lightweight JavaScript
development within the Google
Workspace platform.
Inside the Apps
Script IDE, we're
able to add Google
services to our program
directly through the UI.
This will make
interacting with the APIs
much easier since there's less
setup than using their HTTP
interfaces.
Once we've added the
services we'll be using,
BigQuery, Drive, and Slides,
we're ready to start coding.
First, we'll need to make a
copy of the template slide deck
to use as our
weekly presentation.
Next, we'll loop through each
department, create a new slide,
and then call this function.
Zooming in a bit, you can
see that this function
goes into our new slide and
iterates through each metric.
For each metric, we'll
use this helper function
to call the BigQuery
API and run the UDS
that we created earlier.
Finally, we'll replace
the string containing
the curly brackets
and our metric name
with the result from BigQuery.
When the loop
completes, we'll have
one slide for each department
with all our template
and metrics filled
in appropriately.
And the finishing
touch, since you
need this available for the
director at the beginning
of each week, let's go ahead and
add a trigger to run the script
every Monday morning.
With integrations
across Google services,
you can deliver your data
wherever and whenever
the business needs it.
Leveraging Google Apps
Scripts to automate data
fueled document development
opens up huge opportunities
to save analysts time when it
comes to quarterly business
reviews or financial reporting.
Ready to get started?
Check out the link below
to see some code samples.
[MUSIC PLAYING]